you were doing stand up at like eight
years old is that true i was how is that
possible where are you doing this i was
too fat for t-ball
like did you try to go for t-ball or you
just didn't even try for sports i tried
um but the asthma and the weight it just
didn't asthma overweight great living
with your mom your dad has nothing to do
with you i mean these are
these are things that would [ __ ] up
almost anybody for sure right yeah being
this way is going to be challenging
yeah this is gonna and i think i very
soon after i made a decision that like
as an overweight person true or not this
was what i thought
you walk into a room at a debt like at a
disadvantage people make a snap judgment
about you that you're you know slothful
you lack control
and that it it was incumbent on me to
win them over and i think that's what
inspired comedy and whatnot because i
was like how do i
even i just i don't even want to be
thought of as great i just want to be on
an even playing field as everyone else
so you thought if you were doing
stand-up comedy and you can kind of show
them up and kind of say hey look i'm not
that guy i'm funny i've got i'm creative
i have talent i have all these things so
don't look at me as the fat guy look at
me as a creative funny yeah you know and
what would you make like in your
stand-up would you use your weight as
part of the
joke you know yeah like i had you know
i'm sure they they probably had it in
indiana entenmann's um it was like store
brands and pastries yes yes i don't know
if it's big on the west coast but you
know it's like store brand danish and
donuts and huge on the east coast and
one of my jokes when i was like 10 years
old was i at school i majored in
entomology the study of entemens
[Laughter]
coming out of a little fat kid's mouth
they were like oh this is genius this is
great so i surely was like i'll make fun
of myself first
so you don't have the chance and in
doing so hopefully when you over wow and
this is something you were telling your
mom at a young age i wanna i wanna do
stand-up
yeah i mean she was my mom is like the
ultimate sort of vaudevillian i mean
she's she's 77 right so
her contemporaries were mel brooks and
carl reiner and the true greats of
comedy but she was like the self-made
businesswoman
um a female in the workforce in the 70s
and 80s who like had to deal with a lot
of male [ __ ] and dealing with like
weight and just all this stuff all these
challenges so i would watch her take
over rooms like she was she was very
confident always ready with a joke oh
it's just like a natural she was
overweight yes very overweight always
like you talking about with weight
watchers she was very heavy she would
vacillate sometimes she would be totally
like at a normal weight and it was great
and then she could put on a good amount
of weight quickly so it just was it
yo-yo throughout my whole life did she
date did she date did you see other men
that came into the picture or no never
what oh she's giving me that movie line
like when i you know when you were born
like that ended for me
she never dated after you
not so you don't think your mom since
she had you at 43 has had sex in 30
something years i hope not
i don't want to think about it
i don't know i mean i think probably but
it's like it was probably
she was in such survival mode my whole
whole life and i was just hurt her utter
focus that if she did i'm hoping it was
just a quick fling and i hope they were
nice to her
i hope they use the rubber yeah exactly
i don't mean another one of me out there
like well how did it all start like you
started doing comedy your mom notices
he's got something he's got a spark he's
funny yeah and then what what you went
to an agent you had how did you get an
agent i so i was reading did you ever
when you were starting out as an actor
did you read backstage magazine of
course new york yeah yeah i was not i
was eight or nine years old and this was
before stand up and i find this guy in
the classified sid gold at gold star
entertainment sid gold still around reps
jennifer lawrence no i'm kidding no no
no he doesn't
yeah
jennifer leibowitz though
[Laughter]
but yeah so he i go in and and i meet
him and and the ads like i represent
people of all ages and
and he's a sweet guy and he says listen
i can get you placed at maybe caroline
standup new york i can get you a little
stage time so if you can put together an
act
five minutes of comedy i will get you
stage time how do you and how old are
you eight or nine yeah but how do you
get into a comedy club isn't it like
alcohol and things like that what do
they want a kid who's eight or nine up
there so i started at afternoon shows so
try doing stand up at two yeah nobody
there terrible terrible so i do those
but it was like a
i just had this vision of you i just
said so anyway
and uh okay nobody has the chicken
tenders yeah exactly the thing about
pokemon is like you know you can't do
any crowd work because no one has has my
references um
but yeah and then as i got better at it
and i there was like oh there's like
this
kid comedian who's got this shtick like
maybe we can we can sandwich them in
between real comedians at 11 o'clock at
night they would have to sneak me in so
they wouldn't lose their liquor license
wow yeah like through the back door
anybody famous that you'd go after that
you could recall
or that was up that night i'm trying to
no i mean i remember i was on a tv show
with with a young before half baked
chapelle really and i was like i'm a
comedian too he's like okay what was
that all
it was the tv show was called fox after
breakfast talks after breakfast tom
bergeron really
was on and how old were you i was 11.
i'll show you the picture it's great oh
i have to see it and it and chappelle
was there chappelle couldn't have been
older than 24. do you remember him being
very funny were you like this guy's
really funny yeah i mean i think at that
time i was like oh this guy will get to
my level eventually
you were cocky
yeah i mean i was just like the beauty
of that age where as soon as you're good
at something and especially like it
wasn't being good at athletics at that
age where you're probably good amongst a
lot of good kids i was such an outlier
like a good comedian who had a you know
a good 11 year old comedian was so rare